how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how
though I guess in the British dream it
was successes and failures of post-war
immigration it was a book that was
relatively skeptical about large-scale
immigration and some aspects of
multiculturalism I had previously had a
very close relationship with the Hay
Festival and Peter Florence and when I
had set up Prospect magazine in the mid
1990s and we had a very close
relationship in the early days of the
magazine indeed in the early days of the
Hay Festival you know we would swap our
lists and and we would do events here we
would sponsor events here so I can't
just assume that the book I'd written
you know we were friends at the festival
and I assume this book which came out
perfectly timed as well it came out in
in March or April of 2013 I assumed that
I said to my publishers well you know I
assume that they want me they didn't
want me to a festival so I emailed Peter
and said he was very sweet and honest
about he really sort of said look guy
you know I I'm a liberal I know I'm in
favor of large-scale immigration like
your book made me feel uneasy I didn't
like you so I didn't wanted my festival
perfectly fair have you not noticed
liberals are often very liberal and I
think particularly when it comes to
these these cultural issues in the more
recent book that I wrote that came out
last year called roaches somewhere which
is which is partly about valley
divide the so-called people that see the
world from anywhere and people see the
world from somewhere and the the the
gulf between the book is about that the
gulf between the educated and mobile and
that the combination the two is so
important I think in this country
because because the domination of
residential universities that that to be
educated to be part of the professional
class you have to leave your your home
your hometown and you're often never go
back and with unless you believe in a
few areas of London or Manchester you're
invariably leaving and joining another
network another another another group
and you're socialized into the attitudes
of that group and those attitudes tend
to be the attitudes you would expect
from mobile educated people they tend to
favor openness autonomy they're
comfortable with social fluidity and
they tend to have this is very very
useful distinction from the otherwise
extremely dull American sociologist
toolkit Parsons who talks about human
identity being on a spectrum between
achieved and ascribed I'm an ascribed of
those things about ourselves that we can
do nothing about what am i male British
and achieved identity and most the
people that I call anywheres of people
who have generally speaking achieved
identities and meaning that they their
sense themselves comes from their own
achievements they passed exams when they
were young they went to more or less
good universities they have more or less
good professional careers and their
sense of themselves comes from that and
that makes their sense of identity sort
of mobile so they can fit in anywhere so
they can flow with with the modern
social fluidity and feel comfortable in
a society that to them is in some ways a
kind of random collection of individuals
because they've lost their kind of group
attachments they've lost their group
instincts if you like whereas some ways
have a sense of identity that is still
mainly ascribed you know they are a
Scottish farmer working-class Geordie
Cornish housewife or whatever they're
and these are theatre ident
is that can be discomforted by rapid
social change because your sense of
yourself comes from a place in a group
and I think this is one of the things
that that I of course a real dilemma for
our modern politics is how we find a
settlement between anywheres in some
ways but both of these worldviews are
entirely legitimate I'm them often
critical of the anywhere's I think
they've been over dominant in our
politics which has led to this kind of
rebalancing this pushback that has
created brexit and and Trump but these
are both perfectly decent worldviews but
we have to the task of statesmen like
politicians is to try and find common
ground and I think in many ways it is
that it's the kind of over dominant
liberals who have to concede more and
one of the things they have to concede
is that it is possible to have strong
group attachments whether it's kind of
big abstract national attachments or
more attachments to kind of people like
me people who come from around here kind
of feelings those attachments do not
have to be hostile to outsiders I think
this is a mistake often that the
Liberals make that they are suspicious
of strong group attachments per se I
mean some strong group attachments do
involve hostility to outsiders but I
think in modern Britain that is
generally speaking not the case and I
talked about the Pala the political
world view somewhere as being decent
populist
meaning that they've broadly accepted
the great liberalisation in the last 30
or 40 years on race on gender on on
sexuality you know you extraordinary
turnarounds in majority opinion on these
things and they are basically decent
people but they are often small see
conservatives and modern liberalism has
to find a way of accommodating small see
conservatism and I think it's done a
very poor job in there now you no longer
a liberal I'm not very critical of
liberals and liberalism I mean I I sort
of call myself a political centrist
I mean I I mean I I I didn't know to be
honest I think you know sometimes I call
myself a liberal sometimes it depends on
the context in a way I mean my I would
say my political credo
is I sort of borrowed partly from the
you know the famous American political
scientist Daniel Bell you know end of
our end of ideology cultural
contradictions of capitalism very
interesting guy
he was one of those American
intellectuals who can in New York many
men even with Jewish New York
intellectual a lot of Trotskyist or
communist when they were young Laurel
and moved all the way over into
neoconservatism did they were kind of
one of the cool neoconservative
intellectual inspirations he never went
all the way but he sort of stopped in
the middle and but he had these famously
sometime in the seventies raises he he
was asked about his political cred and
he said I'm a not not quite in these
words but he sort of said more or less
I'm a market friendly social democrat in
economics I'm a liberal in politics and
I'm somewhat conservative in social and
cultural matters and that combination I
think is the kind of hidden majority in
our societies for all sorts of
contingent and historical reasons
neither the parties of the center-left
nor the center-right have managed to
combine those those sort of political
impulses although actually curiously
probably the closest we came to it was
the conservative manifesto in the last
election in 2017 course it got blown up
by the by the dementia tax and and by
and by resumes appalling performances as
leader but it was an interesting I mean
you were they have found prosecute
magazine you edited it but for many many
years this was the the left-leaning
intellectual magazine do your friends on
the left now regard you as a traitor are
you shun some relationships have
essentially and I was a part of part of
a kind of liberal tribe that I am
no longer part of and some people have
taken that very personally and I no
longer get invited to their cocktail
parties you describe I meant to be open
as you say and yet when it comes to
alternative ideas like yours no I mean
this was the point that Michael Gove I
think was making about experts I mean
you know we all you know we all of us
but are but are kind of emotionally
intuitions first and then rationalize
you know we are not creatures of reason
we are rationalizes and that is true the
highly educated as well as the electric
ated the highly educated a better at
disguising including to themselves I
think they're they're they're better at
selecting the facts that support their
arguments but I mean so often you know
their arguments come from from a
pre-existing emotional place you know
they are just emotionally in favor of
large-scale immigration you know they
didn't really know why but they just are
you know it's part of kind of what makes
them it's part of their worldview and so
they you know they then go out and find
there are probably good arguments in
favor of it and they find them in me but
they believe that they have come to
those arguments through reasoning and in
very real and they're they're just as
grupa stand just as tribal as indeed I
have experienced as I've known you I
think about 35 years but we've to go
young Fabian what would I mean in what
way what would the I don't know you must
be in your 60s now what would be the 60
something-year-old David could say to
the 20-something year old David good
luck what would what have you what have
you changed most I think I would
encourage myself to start thinking for
myself earlier than I did oh yeah I mean
I was an absolutely author doctor
liberal right up into my mid late
thirties I think it was actually writing
about immigration that we've in fact
we've I wrote an essay in in I was still
a very Orthodox liberal right
until the early 2000s and then it was
actually David Willetts is to blame
David Willetts did we used to do those
Prospect Road tables on on different
issues we get six or seven really
interesting people around they would
talk for a couple of hours I would then
crunch it down edit it down to four or
five pages we did something a welfare
reform in the early 2000s and Willits
said something that is still too seldom
spoken about he said you said you can
either have you can have a welfare state
you know even a generous welfare state
high degree of solidarity if you have a
society with very strong common
understandings very strong homogeneity
in effect so he was comparing America
with Sweden since he compared it
American Sweden sweeteners have become a
much more diverse societies had very
high levels of immigration in the last
15 years but they know that the
Scandinavian you know homogeneity both
both income ethnic and class terms that
they're very they are like kind of big
families those societies in many ways
and and it's much easier to have high
levels of solidarity very high levels of
public spending and tax in America much
more diverse fragmented society anyway
makes it seems an obvious point but I I
was very struck by it and I could have
thought about it for a while and a year
or two later I wrote this essay in
Prospect called too diverse question
mark did very much at the center left
saying there is this tension between
your these two principles that you that
you admire above others the Solidarity
and diversity you know you've got to
think about this so in there it's not
you know you can mitigate the tension
it's not it's not inevitable and you
might say that we have in many ways
successfully mitigated that tension you
know if you look at welfare spending has
at least until relatively recently has
been increasing we introduced tax
credits in the mid 2000s but you've got
you've got to watch this anyway yes the
Maya same prospect was reprinted in The
Guardian in full and that caused a
little bit of a row man that was when I
first kind of felt that I was some sort
of heretic in relation to my own trial
what I had previously thought was my own
tribe but it was also kind of release
you know I got you know I was able then
to sort of think more freely and I think
more useful even more constructively in
some ways and then I ended up a few
years later writing the book about
immigration but it was that that gave me
a sense you know look I mean I'm very
much anywhere I come from an elite
middle-class background my dad was a
Tory MP so I was a lefty a student and I
couldn't not be really but writing about
immigration made me kind of realize that
there is such a thing in society and
that people can have perfectly
legitimate objections to their society
being changed without their consent that
having you know having you know valuing
security and familiarity are perfectly
reasonable things and those and the
objections to them can be expressed in
perfectly non xenophobic ways as well
often they're not often they are
expressed instead of filmic ways that's
often that's often because people don't
have any other way of it was through
that that I that I came to understand
some of the limits of modern liberalism
and indeed its individualism its kind of
lack of an understanding of groups and
group identities and it is still what
yeah and it remains one of its great
weaknesses I think it's a very bad at
creating you know big national
collective stories and identities I mean
that's what you know we were all so
overjoyed by the great Danny Boyle 2012
Olympic story because we have these we
have these things so seldom and in that
case it wasn't even a politician who did
it great fantastic now I'm not sure
Davey can do the other way around
because well I've been a television
journalist all my life
since I left University and covering
British politics I suppose I've
developed a particular style a
challenging style particular when it
comes to you know the misdemeanors of
politicians a lot of covering elections
in elections but I also as a sideline
really and at one point it was quite a
lucrative sideline written a lot of
books mainly biographies and they tend
to be biographies of people who've had
more than one career so sort of like
Michael Heseltine who was a incredibly
successful businessman and also an
incredibly successful politician which
enabled you to look at his career in
perspective in in a funny way but I'm
now writing a book about for the first
time in my life I'm writing a book with
the subject cooperation I'm writing a
book about Sir David Butler the father
really of election science in this
country who had a huge influence not
just on the way in which we understand
why people vote and changes in the way
they vote but also had a huge influence
on the way in which television covers
elections on the way in which on the
whole genre of contemporary history
instant history he was a great developer
of that through his series of British
election books and there's a whole
school of safale gists that was a term
that he actually promoted who were all
the sons and daughters of David Butler
there either ex-colleagues taught by him
encouraged by him and it's actually of
all the books I've written it's the one
that's been the most enjoyable do you
think there is anything though in the
charge that the much greater regression
of modern political journalism yes I
think there is something in that and it
does worry me and I think that when I
first covered politics for ITN in the
1980s and I was briefly a member of the
lobby then it was all far too
deferential people did not ask
challenging or cheeky questions enough
people did not or even worse than that
they knew that with things going on that
were wrong going on I mean for instance
the whole expensive story journalists
knew about that
the MPs expenses story they knew about
that thirst and forty years ago people
in the lobby political journalists at
Westminster but because of their
relationships with politicians which
they wanted to maintain they they didn't
want to delve deeply into that they
didn't want to ruin their relationships
and also I think there was a culture
whereby everybody thought it was all a
bit of a laugh and so that that
atmosphere is now largely gone but I do
think in some ways we've gone too far
the other way that we always jump to the
conclusion that politicians are up to no
good a lot of the time politicians are
can be quite dishonest or at least less
than frank with us but I think that
perhaps we don't and enough of the time
we don't give them the benefit of the
doubt we don't appreciate the fact that
they have immense pressures on them
they're not just coming to deal with
their constituencies in a way that they
never did before that they are expected
to come up with instant answers instant
solutions to problems as well as leading
ordinary lives as human beings coping
with their families all the crises at
home we never I think there is a lack of
appreciation of that amongst political
journalists and I I include myself in
that so I think there is something in
your charge here and indeed that you
might say that part of the job politics
often is to is to be evasive to fudge
the constructive ambiguity gave us most
other things that could fry the
agreement you know if if people have
been absolutely straight as you were
demanding that they be more difficult to
come to these kinds of difficulties that
may be true in terms of the Good Friday
Agreement but I think in a lot of other
cases it's contributed to public
disillusionment with politics a feeling
that they never give a straight answer a
lot of the time when I've been a lot of
time you interview a politician and you
ask them 10 questions and they don't
answer any of the questions there are
exceptions to this I mean somebody like
Tony Blair actually did answer a lot of
the questions you put to them put to him
and it never did it didn't do him any
harm actually
but you hear I mean I think both Theresa
May and Jeremy Corbyn are both guilty of
this never wanting to answer the
question it's almost as if a politician
regards it as a sign of weakness
if they answer a question directly or if
they admit well I don't know yet or I
haven't thought about that yet well
we're still thinking about that and
there are arguments on both admitting
that there are there is doubt there that
they don't have the solutions to
everything I think actually a little bit
more frankness bit more honesty from
politicians at times in response to
questions rather than public evasive nos
they're almost trained to be evasive now
they're trained in phrases like well
what we've said is you know the number
of times a young junior MP or minister
will start their answers what we've said
on this is or they've worked out the set
soundbite in advance I mean it got to
the stage with Gordon Brown where he
would never answer a question and I
always said I always thought of saying
well mr. Brown what's the answer to my
next question
because and it's so so off-putting to
the British public and I think that
while some you know the aggression of
some journalists like myself may have
contributed to the public
disillusionment with politics I think
politicians haven't done themselves any
favours you could argue that invasion
Commons partly from the more ferocious
context this is quite interesting you go
back 50 or 60 years you know the famous
you know do you have anything to say to
the British public which was partly a
class thing that the journalists were
often from middle or lower middle class
backgrounds they were not graduates on
the whole and that will change from the
sort of 70s 80s onwards and now the
people that are top journalists come
from exactly the same backgrounds
exactly the answer the same you know
qualities or whatever and they are
thinking I could do this job better than
him or her
whereas generations ago they would
indeed I mean and indeed you know I was
at university with Theresa Bay and an
unstable of her cabin
and some on the labor side as well now
I'm not at one point I did have
aspirations to go to politics not
anymore and I'm not sure I could do the
job any better than them
and I'm not sure I certainly wouldn't
have the energy that is required and so
yes I think there is a feeling that
we're talking to equals and it wasn't
just in McMillen's time that you know
they were they were middle class and
that there was a social driving some of
them would have even become from working
class backgrounds as well so and and
it's a pot yard I hadn't thought about
it like that
now there's a phrase that politicians
ought to say a bit more yeah I would be
if politicians were actually willing to
turn around and say yes actually I
hadn't quite thought about it like that
I'll go I won't think about it a bit
more I tell you the moment I'm looking
for on television is the moment we're on
television or on radio there is a
discussion going on between two
protagonists and one of them turns
around and says you know David the
points you've raised they're fascinating
I really haven't thought about it in
those terms before and yes you've
persuaded me yes I can see one do you
now moving on to the kind of
disappearances mainstream television
mainstream journalism is struggling for
its life we're often told do you worry
that that political communication to
mass publics is now increasingly coming
from highly partisan sources on the
Internet or elsewhere who's going to
contribute to a there are all sorts of
developments that are going on some of
which are very worrying and others of
which aren't I mean the worrying ones
are the decline of newspaper readership
which is now turned about what 40% of
what it was 15 years ago
the decline of local newspapers a lot of
them have disappeared and the ones that
remain are pretty poor compared with
what they used to be the decline of
audiences for television
the decline of television and current
affairs all of those are very worrying
trends on the other hand the rise of
social media of people journalism the
tweeting and websites and all sorts of
social social media some of which I'm
not even familiar with myself has
actually brought more people into
journalism or political debate I think
there are probably more people involved
in politics more people involved in
political debate than there ever were
and I am confident that the
accountability process of journalism is
is as robust as ever
it's just robust in different areas you
know one of the roles of journalists is
to hold people in power to account and
in many ways we do that much better than
we did 30 years ago and you and I set
out or 40 years ago when we set out as
as journalists but it's patchy
inevitably
and it also worries me that yes we are
becoming increasingly that the political
debate is conducted between platforms
that are very much
polarized and that our politicians are
avoiding the traditional mainstream
media - and using these platforms
instead so for instance you know a few
months ago there was a captain and what
the issue was now but Corbin was under
huge pressure over something I think it
was anti-semitism actually and instead
of doing an interview with channel 4
news or ITN or the BBC he actually spoke
to camera and made a 30 from 90 second
statement which we then all boycotted on
the grounds that we weren't going to
encourage him to do that sort of thing
that he was going to make statements we
should have the power to ask him
questions at the end of it but it was
the beginning of a it was an
illustration of a worrying trend the
other illustration is the National Union
Station of that is the way in which both
treason may and Jeremy Corbyn never
allow themselves to be questioned at
length apart from in occasionally in a
general election I've never seen Corbin
or Mei do
long television interview they never do
long press conferences anymore in the
way in which only five or ten years ago
David Cameron Gordon Brown Tony Blair
all of the political leaders regularly
did and that is a worrying trend as well
I wish I could stay longer
I just come today I'm doing an event
tomorrow morning on liberalism and
tribalism
some of the things we were just talking
about and with honesty brie and eagle
and I've been what I think three years
in the past and shared panel discussions
and hugely enjoyed doing that and also
enjoyed the the post-match stuff as well
you know the dinner and meeting
interesting people and chatting to them
about things that you might not be the
opportunity to chat with them about and
I said I said to the orgonite they
invited me this year to do one of it
and I said well can I do two events
please because that way I can stay
longer and so I've done two events and
had even greater fun this year apart
from the weather exchange yeah yeah get
your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival how the
light gets in org